this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies I've done a video on solar
panels and I've done a video on
batteries but neither of these methods
is how we generate most of our power so
how do we generate most of our power
magnetic induction I wanted to make this
video for a long time let's do this
it seems natural to start with the name
magnetic induction the word induction
comes from the root word induce which
just means to cause something by
persuasion or influence in this case
magnetism induces electricity this
method of generating electricity isn't
anything new I mean it's almost two
centuries old to the dime line all the
way back in 1831 Michael Faraday was
doing a series of experiments some
involving coils and others discs but I'm
getting a bit ahead of myself
we can understand induction was
something simpler than a coil a current
and a long straight wire will do any
moving charge will generate a magnetic
field we call that an electromagnet so
let's say we've got a long straight wire
carrying an electric current since
current is moving charge that wire will
generate a magnetic field if there's
another wire carrying another current
inside of that field it will be affected
by that field in this case the wire is
pushed sideways that push is a magnetic
force which is part of the
electromagnetic force you can see here
it requires the charge to be moving wait
how does all this relate to magnetic
induction patients question clone
patients okay sure one current exerts a
force on another current using magnetic
field
nothing crazy there but this process is
completely reversible if the current in
a wire can be pushed sideways by a
magnetic field then pushing a wire
sideways in a magnetic field should
cause a current and that's exactly what
happens that's magnetic induction we've
induced a current through motion in a
magnetic field that's it well yeah I
never said this was complicated people
make this out to be so magical sometimes
but it's just about reversibility moving
charge in a wire this way gives us an
effect
that way all we've done with induction
is swap the arrows we've moved the wire
sideways to push the current along they
have to be perpendicular because cross
products but the cool thing is it
doesn't even matter which wire you move
a current will be induced in the second
wire regardless while this setup gives
us a simple understanding of induction
unfortunately it's not very practical AC
wall sockets almost always operate at 50
to 60 Hertz that means I'd have to
wiggle this wire back and forth 50 to 60
times per second which is kind of
ridiculous hmm what's something else
that cycles that we can reverse what
about an electric motor you know that
might actually work we can build a
simple motor using a battery a magnet
some insulated wire and a few other
things just to hold it all together you
wrap the wire into a coil and set it up
so current will run through it all it
needs is a little nudge to get started
and it'll spin as long as it has energy
from the battery just like the straight
wire case charge is moving through the
coil wire inside a magnetic field so
there's a force on it now let's put that
thing down flip it and reverse it just
this server may never flood and I don't
like work it I need a glass of water
anyway what happens if we remove the
battery and just spin the coil by hand
doing this should induce a current just
like moving our wire did before well at
least if we have somewhere for that
current to go what do you get if it's
just sitting there not connected to
anything a voltage that's just energy
per unit charge it's the energy the
charges need to move forward to make a
current if they could in this case you
might not have a current yet but there's
still a potential for one get it a
potential because another name for
voltage is electric potential the point
is a simple electric generator is just a
backwards motor back in 1831 Faraday was
generating voltage by moving coils
around in spinning disks we've just
combined those ideas by spinning coils
so how much voltage does it generate
well that depends
in order to make predictions about
anything physics related we need an
equation the concepts discovered by
Faraday weir
written mathematically until about 1885
when Oliver Heaviside properly unified
electricity and magnetism that's why the
law describing magnetic induction is
called heavy signs law just kidding
it's called Faraday's law I'd like to
tell you that's because Heaviside
already had a bunch of stuff named after
him like Laplace unfortunately that's
not true
Heaviside really got shafted here but
let's try to read a Faraday's law in
plain English on the left there is the
result we're looking for a voltage on
the right we've got the cause of that
voltage a change over time the N is just
the number of loops in our coil the Phi
is the magnetic field on an area also
known as magnetic flux the fact that
it's called flux isn't important though
you know what forget I even mentioned it
our coil has maybe ten loops in it so N
equals ten
nice and easy the coil also forms a
circular area in area that has a
magnetic field inside it the field
inside that area multiplied by the area
itself is that Phi symbol then we
multiply by 10 because there are 10
loops and bam we've got a number we can
use in Faraday's law that number changes
because the loops are spinning sometimes
they have a lot of magnetic field inside
them sometimes only a little bit
sometimes none and according to
Faraday's law that change gives us a
voltage our backwards motor transforms
the energy from my hand into electrical
energy of course turning this by hand is
a lot of work I'd rather not do having
hamsters or clothes running in wheels
would be a lot less work for me but
that's not very scalable this method
might be 200 years old but we've gotten
a lot better at engineering it so how do
we generate most of our power by making
coils spin inside magnetic fields wind
power the wind turns the blades which
are attached to a coil water power the
flowing water turns a coil coal or
natural gas the heat from burning it
boils water into steam the steam turns a
coil nuclear the heat from the reactor
boils water into steam the steam turns a
coil in every case we're using a
magnetic field to transform some other
energy into useful electrical energy
most of our electrical energy is made
through magnetic induction
it's just that some source energies are
better for the environment than others
so did this clear up any misconceptions
you had about induction let us know in
the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us until next time remember it's okay to
be a little crazy
if phosphorous is so great for solar
panels why not just use that and forget
about the silicon that would change how
the atoms bond to each other and what
energy levels they have we want there to
be only four bonds and we need the
bandgap to be the size of a photon of
visible light you're not going to get
that with just phosphorous ok crazies
thanks for watching